the last kilometer or so to the
front-line trenches of this conflict in
eastern ukraine is always by foot
the separatists positions are never far
away
the trenches that now stretch hundreds
of miles in higgledy-piggledy length are
defensive
but essentially they're an overwatch
system to keep an eye on the movement of
the russian-backed separatists and more
importantly any incursion by the russian
army and there's been more activity
at night particularly yeah we're
surrounded conditions here are miserable
and dangerous
the troop commander explained our
position essentially in the middle of
the separatists i understood
the soldiers say in recent weeks there's
been more activity and more firing from
the separatist side
the snowy hilliken towers are their
opponent's lines it really isn't far at
all
it is easy to forget that this conflict
has been going on since 2014
the scars of the fighting are everywhere
abandoned and destroyed buildings litter
the landscape
the villages and towns on the front line
aren't always deserted but they're very
quiet now and few people venture outside
if they can avoid it well these towns in
eastern ukraine are very remote but they
were very very busy those things have
changed now because
they are actually the front line
when you see things like this as your
houses that took
direct hits by
rockets from the separatist side it's
easy to understand
why most people have decided to get out
of town the only ones who have stayed
behind now are really those who can't
get out and have got nowhere to go
72 year old olga mihai lovna has stayed
behind with her husband the rest of her
extended family left as the fighting
intensified her sister's house was
destroyed
she's scared but isn't moving
us
while the diplomatic moves and prime
ministerial meetings take place both in
ukraine and abroad the fact is that the
two sides are stuck
battle lines drawn and to them there's
nothing to suggest things will change
there is a real sense that this freezing
front line is frozen waiting for some
sort of breakthrough that could relieve
the tension
that or another round of bloodshed
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine